Okay.
Hey, what's going on?
It's Bill Burr and It's time for the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
September 11th, 2017 what's going on? How are you?
How's it going? How's it going? Um, more hurricanes,
more hurricanes.
And this is the 17th anniversary of the attacks in the World Trade Center,
the Pentagon, and then the one that went down in Pennsylvania, you know, I mean,
Jesus Christ, what is going on this week?
It's just all gloom and frigging doom. You know,
I was sitting there watching the news with Nia, right?
And this show and highlights of this, um, was it hurricane or say is,
what is it? Jim are safe. Who is coming into fucking Miami, right?
And there's some fucking, you know, white dude out there of course being like,
well, you know, it's know coming down real hard.
They show like five white people out there. And Nia literally said to me,
she goes, what is wrong with white people?
Yeah, the lab. I was like, you know, we, for the most part,
we grew up in cul-de-sacs. There's no excitement.
There's no drive by zig. No. Uh, you know,
cops beat me up for no reason. Generally speaking, you know, it's kind of, hey,
knock it off over there, straighten up. I know your father. You know,
it's kind of like that. So I guess, you know, hurricane comes around you.
You need a story. Shit. You need a story.
I have no idea why I came up with a hacky eighties joke though about fucking the
hurricanes. It's let's,
it's why don't they have all the peoples Dan with a report?
Because the report has never died.
They're always standing in the fucking middle of the shit. I don't know how,
I don't know how these news agencies know exactly where to fucking stand,
but somehow they stand just enough in the shit. I don't buy it. I don't buy it.
Um, she has one of them died yet,
you know,
out of fuck. I mean, how the fuck do that, you know, Jesus, Belle spit it out.
Sorry. I floated a once. I, I've, I'm already done, but once I fly it, it just,
you know, breathe in that fucking pressurized air up there.
Um, I mean, it's fucking inevitable.
If you stand out inside in a fucking hurricane sums gonna fall on top of it.
It's bad enough. Like I love when they sit there and they tell these people,
you need to evacuate. You gotta get out of there. It's like and go where?
To my summer home.
Don't you remember the fucking bags left it half this country upside down in
their fucking house. It's fucking unreal.
I don't understand like where these people are supposed to go. Like, where did,
where do they go?
Everybody just goes north and sits in a fucking waffle house for three,
four days. All the hotels get bought up. And if you don't have money,
what do you, what are you supposed to do? Um,
anyways, at least it was knocked down to a, to a category three, man.
I read some fucking, you know, at some horrible shit about, uh,
Houston that's still going on now is all mold and there's all in the, you know,
you don't need to listen to this. You see it all fucking day.
This is just gloom and doom, all fucking misery here. So, um,
why don't I go to something positive? I actually, a friend of the podcast,
one of the great traumas of all time, Steven Adler, uh, he sent me this thing.
He's got a, uh, they're doing something for Ronnie James Dio. Um,
on October 6th at 6:30 PM bowl for Ronnie celebrity.
Uh, Christ, my eyes are going celebrity bowling tournament. All right, now,
fuck, I'm not gonna be able to read this. I can't. Okay, here we go. Oh.
Gotta love that. You can enlarge it. Wish I could do this to the world, man.
I have to get glasses. Why would I just give in to the fact that I need glasses?
All right. October six, 2017,
6:30 PM celebrity bowling tournament. Bowl for Ronnie.
Oh, for God's sake. Steven. Where's it going to be at? Oh,
it pins bowling center. One, two,
six five five Ventura Boulevard, studio city,
California 906 oh four go down there.
It's for a great cause and a, you know, have yourself a white Russian,
you know, and tell Dani to shut the fuck up. Okay.
And I'll be down there for a great cause. Alrighty.
They at Gov I'll have put up a link. I'm going to post the whole uh,
flyer on a, the Monday morning thing of a Jig.
There's another guy got the TV on the am on my Twitter account.
There's a guy standing out there,
Jesus Christ standing out there in the fucking rain.
Like the video. Al Roker is out there.
How many hurricanes is that poor bastard stood down and now it's going up to
Tampa.
Then it looks like it's going to go right over the Florida gators football
stadium, somehow die around fucking making Georgia.
And is that what they said? Is that the trajectory? I don't know what.
Um, anyways, um,
so I was in a miss ship flew into fucking miss [inaudible] on Thursday night and
I missed the entire New England patriots game.
And from what I've heard as a patriots fan was probably better to just landed,
find out that they got the shit kicked out of them.
Really just kind of in the fourth quarter though. I mean,
it was kind of a shootout with no fucking defense as far as I could tell. Um,
the chiefs are all excited doing fucking cartwheels cause they let up fucking 27
points. I don't know what they're so fucking excited about,
but I will tell you as a patriots fan, I'm pretty fucking happy.
I'm going to tell you why I want to tell you why,
because I don't like the fucking worst thing ever is when before you even start
the season, those fucking hacks on the sports shows go. You know,
they talk about your team like good N***a, right? They start doing that shit.
So before the fucking season, our restarts,
you already got that fucking monkey on your back.
Every fucking fat Douche who never got picked in gym class coming in with this
fucking loafers in his sweaters in India locker room,
just trying to rip the team apart and just adding just distraction.
So right out of the gate we fucking lose. All of that is gone.
And then immediately they go, Whoa, Whoa, wait a minute. Wait a minute.
Remember when you say and Tom Brady is after his last game was the greatest
without a doubt of all time.
Now we're the exact same people one fucking game later saying he's too old,
so I'm loving that. I'm loving all of that. What would you know?
I would actually love if we lost next week too,
but then they would have all those,
you know what's good as a time to hit the panic,
Blah Blah [inaudible] you'd have to deal with that. So I'm open,
you know they were in the next three, four they lose another one,
four and two and then they're five. Just nobody's paying attention. No,
they treat us like the Indianapolis Colts man when they were 13 and o and nobody
said Shit for whatever fucking reason,
which is really a reoccurring thing with the Indianapolis Colts.
No matter what they do. Hearing aids in the fucking helmets,
fucking pumping crowd noise in tank in the final third of the season to get
Andrew luck stealing the patriots off offense.
Fucking being on the rules committee,
changing the rules of passing and on and on and fucking on. Right.
Go on 13 and oh, nobody's saying shit.
Oh they're just a bunch of country boys out there.
We won't pay attention to them. I love it. I love that we, uh,
I mean I hate our fucking defense,
but I haven't liked our defense since we won our first three. Um,
I think ever since then we've always been like, uh, you know,
well we're going to score you already gonna score 35, we're going to score 38.
I always just, I just Kinda feel like we've been like that for too long.
And occasionally we've brought,
we brought in a shutdown corner like a Reavis um,
oh they ain't tailor whatever the fuck his name was who was here for like a year
or two. He was fucking great. But then all of a sudden they're like, yeah,
okay now I want to get paid. They like, yeah, Nah, Nah.
So, um, anyways, yeah. So I just,
I watched a little bit of the highlights. I mean,
when you give up an 85 yard touchdown in your corner,
like fucking lets the guy go by him cause he thinks that he's got help over the
top and the guy just isn't there. I mean,
I really don't think that's the chief's kicking our ass as much as that's
um,
just horrible defense. You know what I mean?
I would say though that that guy running for like 6,000 yards against us is
definitely a concern. But you know,
what are we supposed to win it every fucking year? You know?
Am I right with it? I love it. I love it. So there we go. So now what?
Now what we go 11 and five. They'll fix it, but I don't know.
You know, we do,
we always fucking have guys and then they make the pro bowl and then they asked
for more money than we let them go and then we've got to build it back up again.
So we'll see. It is definitely towards the end of Tom Brady's career. You know,
I don't know how it could have gone any fucking better.
Um,
you know, what are you going to tell me if it's a fist? You know, you don't,
why so many people out about that, aside
from the fact that they hate the patriots, it's, that's how people,
that's how most people live their lives. You know,
they take one loss and they just pack it in.
Oh No, we're never going to,
and I'm including a lot of patriots fans, you know, those ag,
but she can never listen to those sports shows.
Cause even like the people who call in, you know,
they always use words like concerned.
I'll tell you right now,
I'm really concerned about our patch defense on dirt towns.
Are you, what are you concerned about as if you're like, you're,
you're a part of the coaching staff and if it doesn't work,
you're going to get fired.
You're gonna have to put your house up for sale and reload.
You relocate your kids once again. What exactly are you concerned about?
Um, but congratulations. The chiefs, I've actually,
I've always liked the chiefs. Um,
I used to always watch the Superbowl highlights and that one with tank stream,
you know, 64 toss power. Trappers was always like the one of the great ones.
She's sitting there laughing his fucking balls off and everybody loved that back
then. But now if they had that audio,
he'd have to issue an apology to the Minnesota Vikings and bud grant in the
family and all that bullshit. But um, so anyways,
I was flying back from Alabama and uh,
so the only football games I was able to catch, I watched the uh,
Greenbay Seattle game, which I know Seattle fans hate, cause they,
they definitely seem like they were getting the short end of the stick.
Certainly on that phantom punches a injection, which I didn't see.
I just saw the replay of it. Of course it happened on a fucking pig. Six.
Always fun to watch p Carroll loop blow a fucking gasket.
But that guy is a great coach and that's, that's a great defense.
You know what I mean? The fucking legion to do, you know, legion of boom, sorry,
boom. Right in your ass with the steroids.
Yeah.
Fuck all you guys. If you're going to bring up every fucking God damn time,
Jesus Christ, we bend a card in fucking New England.
I'm fucking trash in everybody.
I am doing research on all your fucking teams and I'm going to do what you guys
do every fucking time. You give me shit about my, I'm fucking fine.
I'm going to fucking look in the corners of your franchise. Jesus Christ.
Like 30% of that fucking team tested pause,
defense tested positive for fucking steroids and they're still just talking
about how great they are. Unbelief. Oh, that's another Colt's one.
The gout caught the fucking allegedly deflated ball,
which was never fucking proven.
Um,
it's never fucking proven yet. Tom Still got fucking suspended.
Everybody's basically paying the price for the under suspension of Ray Rice.
I think when they go into Roger Goodell. Um,
how see that the Patriots lost after the, uh,
those barstool guys had that hilarious tee shirt of him just like a fucking
clown. Is there anything better than just cone? Say's a fucking clown.
Okay.
All your accomplishments just go right out the window there. Fucking guy,
Roger Goodell makes million dollars a year, $30 million a year.
As you can catch a walk into his car and you go, Hey dad,
you're a fucking clown. I'm telling you,
as much as he has $30 million puppy civic, 16 after taxes, it bugs him.
He's going to be thinking about it when he's drinking his little donkeys,
coffee in the morning. Fuck is that guy to call me a clown talking himself.
You know, when he's putting his suit on, he's got the jacket, tie and shirt.
He looks like one of those guys. He gets everything on, he puts the pants on.
Last Clooney area has his shoes on with the fucking socks in the sock.
Garters you've got him talking to himself as he's adjusting the nut in the
fucking the knot right there and then in the mirror. Um,
so anyways, so I watched that game and uh, the defense is, uh,
looked obviously great in those fucking games. And uh, and now I got the,
I got the cowboys and giants in the background. Um,
I did watch the Moto GP race. I just watched the, uh, the big boys.
I didn't get to watch a motor GP, three or two,
but what a fucking race about mark mark has just saying, you know,
David Cialis is just like, hey man, I'm going to take,
I'm gonna take the bucket point. So mark, mark has is like, fuck that.
Fuck that.
I'm going for the victory for you guys and all watch motorcycle racing.
It was raining out and they still race. They don't quite go as fast,
but they were going like over 150 miles an hour in the fucking rain on each
other's asses. And this guy a, what the fuck was his name? He started the race.
He fucking shot right up the side into first place.
What the Fuck is being able to pee? I can't, I don't, I'm new to this sport.
I don't know all their names. So anyways,
now it was that guy a bill.
Why don't you just look the shit up so he can talk? You know what happened?
He just can't remember the fucking names. What was the guy's name? Larry Legend.
Is that the guy who fucking shot up and first before he fucking wiped out,
there's more goddamn accidents today or yesterday,
I should say when they were racing. And uh, anyways,
everything that Formula One needs MotoGP has,
it was a race right down to the end. And fucking Mark Marquez said, fuck this.
I'm going for the points. Cause if he got the 25,
he was going to be tied with the visio.
So he passed them on the fucking last lap or second to last lap and then held
them off. Um, you know, it was some Phil Mickelson Shit. You know,
I'm not going to fucking, you know, just try to get back out on the fairway.
I'm going to try to put it in the hall.
Then I'm going to for pot and walk away with sweaty tits. I mean,
that's what this man did, but basically on a motorcycle.
So that was very enjoyable. But let's get down.
Let's talk about going down south now that the patriots season is evidently over
and Tom Brady is a over the health. Um,
you know the Atlanta Falcons one today in the New England patriots lost the
exact opposite thing that happened the last time. Um, so there you go.
I don't know what that means. I'm sure Atlanta Falcon fans,
if they could switch, you know, the results with the Patriots,
I think they would, you know, but evidently the fucking football sky is falling.
Um, you don't even fucking hate about fantasy football.
That is literally taken over like um,
they used to have like in the sports pages they used to just have,
they would have like the leaders. It was something,
it was really easy to find the leaders.
You could collect football cards and shit.
I used to know so much more about the game.
I don't know anybody's fucking name anymore.
Anytime you go to any sort of website where they have like fantasy fate,
when you want to look at stats, it's all this fantasy football shit.
Get this guy on your team.
Peyton Manning's fucking advertising that stuff.
I don't know. Should I just give in? Should I just give, I don't want it.
I don't want to do that shit.
I don't want to have somebody on a team that I actually,
I don't really hate any other team in the NFL. Do I hate any team?
I Hate Jim [inaudible]. That's it. That's the only person I don't like.
You know,
there's certain people that act like fucking idiots in the league that I don't
particularly care for, but that I don't hate the team. You know,
here's another classic.
The cowboys are probably gonna beat the giants cause this is what the cowboys
and giants do. The cowboys when in the beginning,
part of the year and then the giants always fucking losing in the end.
They come back around and they do the same thing down in New York.
So time to move on from Eli.
He only steps up in every fucking big moment in January his entire career.
I think it's time to get rid of him cause he fucked up in September.
Um, you know, I didn't even allow me to look this shit up.
Did that as Zko Elliot guy play seems to me a,
what's weird is they threw out his case in the real world,
but it's like in the NFL you need less burden of proof.
Elliott cowboys. Is that his fucking name?
Uh,
okay.
Elliott cowboys to play.
Is he playing judge grants champion or a restraining order request for Dallas
cowboys running back? Probably from that psycho.
What would the person who seeming like a psycho. Okay.
Is he cause he go Elliott ruly makes, yeah, I've been out of the loop.
All right, so you played, that's good. That's good.
Cause the clown was going to over suspend them. The elegant get this.
The NFL is back. And so what the 15 reasons, it's a complete disaster.
Hey,
y'all bought those Los Angeles Rams coming back wearing the Lamar Lundy fucking
blue and white. The fearsome foursome. Marlin Olson.
Rosie Griff. Was it Lamar? London? You always forget him and then a,
what's his face there? Uh, I can never name all four of them.
I always end up forgetting one. I always remember Merlin Olsen Rosey Greer.
Oh Jesus Christ. The coolest.
One of them are Deacon Jones and it was at Lamar Lundy, Lamar,
Lamar Lundy. Is this even a podcast? Is this,
you guys listen to me fucking yeah, there you go. Right. Lamar Lundy,
was he a Steeler or was he a Ram? He was a he ram Lamar and warranted rams.
Fierce foursome. I right. I got
it. All right. So anyway, let's get, let's, let's, I'm not watching TV anymore.
Now I'm focused. Now I'm focused. Oh, is Eli driving him in?
Okay.
Once he got his second and eight, eight oh nine to go in the third quarter,
Eli calling a fucking audible over the middle, far out fairs,
down, moving the ball.
Cowboys fans are all going to be fuck saying you need to fucking bench fucking
quarterback and bring back Roger Star back. Um, so we did the, uh,
the Horseshoe Casino in Mississippi. I had so much fucking fun doing that.
Um,
although it was just a part of the south man that was just deep, deep, deep,
deep south, deep south. Hang a fucking right.
Don't stop in Alabama. Keep going. Stop. Right before you get to fucking
Louisiana. And, um, it was just was,
I don't know, the pace of the people down there was driving me fucking nuts.
You know, I ordered room service twice.
I kept ordering water and they just wouldn't bring it up to me.
So the second time I said, did you, where's the glass?
Is there a glass of water? And she's like, well now try.
And I'm like, and, and that's what's on the try.
She just fucking walks out. There's no, Oh,
I'm sorry. I'll go get you some. It's like it wasn't on the tray.
So then I go to use like nothing fucking worked.
I go to use the fucking ironing board. The ironing board was fucked up.
I was trying to make it stand up. It wouldn't stand up.
I had to bend a piece back. It wouldn't,
and then I finally just had a fucking meltdown and I'm admitting this to the
casino. I jumped up and down on it and then I pulled this shark nose back.
I felt bad afterwards and I tried to bend it back, but it's all fucked up.
If you wonder why it's fucked up. I finished it off. It was already fucked up.
So if you want to send me a bill, I apologize. Um,
and then the next day, me, Dean and Nick drove over into, uh,
Tuscaloosa to go on.
We went to go see Alabama versus Fresno state. Uh,
we had a great fucking time. Um, we met some people there,
some friends of mine and a, they hooked us up. We were in,
I think that's fucking skybox. No Sunburn. You know, it was a cupcake game.
Who's kidding? Who Against Fresno state. It was a day game. It's like I went,
but I have to go back there again.
I want to go there and night game when they play like Texas a and M,
Mississippi or fucking, you know,
anybody like LSU or some shit like that.
I want to go back for that and I want to sit in the fucking crowd the next time.
Um, this was like, it was too nice. It was awesome. I had a great time,
but it was like a, I didn't, I didn't get to feel the crowd a little bit,
which was perfect because I had a show that night, so I didn't drink.
I'm still not drinking and I didn't get a sunburn, so it worked out for me,
but I feel like I kind of went to a preseason game. Um,
so we're walking out of there and fucking Joe Barton x somehow found the one
Russian guy in Alabama and shit escalated quickly.
You know, bardic walks up to the guy, that guy, uh,
I don't know how they got into a conversation. The Guy said he was,
somehow he said he,
he always heard his talk and he meant he said something to us.
We were waiting for the elevator and the guy said that he was rushing.
So bar next, a huge penguins fan. And he goes,
oh. He's like, oh, you're a Russian. He goes, hey, you know, you like, Oh mom,
can you have getting him all going, right? Yeah. You're like, Maga.
The guy's like, Nah, Nah.
He's like, I like it. He's like, I let go of that skit. And then he goes,
you're like, get back shit.
And then he gets right in the guy's face and he goes, zero cups, zero cups.
He's like a vege Kinney goes and starts doing the choking thing. Right.
Okay.
Joe had had a couple of SAS Barillas who's kidding who, right?
So they fucking start going back and forth and the e Joe keeps giving them shit.
The guy's going, oh, come on man. It's a team game. [inaudible]
guys your cup. So how can you like zero cups?
Zero Cup keeps it
acting like the guy's choking on a fucking Dick and the Russian guys getting
mad. Joe's fucking around. He's not seeing it.
And the fucking elevator cannot come fast enough cause it looks like it's going
to escalate into a fight. Which, you know,
Joe Barnick and this Russian guy was actually taller than Joe,
but he was skinnier. But you know, we sell so Russian, you know what I mean?
So you know, you know those fucking people, they, they'd be,
they beat the fucking bitch. Slapped Hitler all the way back to fucking Berlin.
You know, let people out of prisons and say, Hey,
remember we threw you in there for,
why don't you come out and go do that to people who look like this?
And that's what they did. Half of them were in bare feet. I mean,
I know it's a legend at this point, but it's pretty much fucking true.
So now I'm concerned because they're both Joe's like whatever, six, four,
this guy's like six, five, and G. I kept going, Joe, hey man. Hey Joe,
take it easy. Just kept,
go ahead guys that don't come say wait, come on.
They just kept doing it and he's laughing at the guy.
Yeah. And I don't know why. He just wasn't seeing the guy getting mad.
So the guy goes, hey, why don't we go around the corner and Joseph Guy,
let's go around the corner and they walk around the corner. I'm like,
are they going to go fight?
And then there was this awkward little moment between him and me and dean is
stone sober? Like what the fuck? So finally I just go to my buddy goes,
there's some stairs we can take as the elevator was taken forever. And he goes,
uh, yeah. I go, yeah, we can take the stairs.
So we go to take the stairs and we're going to walk out.
And the Russians guys like, I wouldn't take this day out as too,
now they walk in Belden stairs and it's just like I couldn't separate them.
I couldn't get them separated. And uh,
I dunno what happened by the end of it. They were,
they were like best of friends ready to go drink some fucking vodka. Um,
we actually left the game, uh,
halfway through the fourth quarter because we had to go do our show,
but we wanted to go around and get a picture in front of the bear Bryant Statue.
And, uh, we actually got one in front of the Nick Saban one.
There's one other guy that nobody,
everybody always forgets he's only won one championship,
but it was pretty fucking amazing to, uh, to go there. I'm telling you, if you,
if you get a fucking chance, man, everybody wants to go to the ballparks,
all the baseball parks and go to a fucking Lambeau field and that type of shit,
which I understand,
but you know all you guys who live in pro football cities and you know New York,
Chicago, all that pro shit,
Boston don't sleep on going to big time college football man.
I'm telling you sec, big 10, you got to go to the University of Michigan.
You got to go to horseshoe in a house state. You got to go to one of them.
You just have to experience 100,000 fucking people going absolutely fucking
nuts. Pick a good rivalry game. Go on fucking stubhub, pay through the nose,
go out there and get fucking hammered.
Go to the game and then please tell me what you see in the NFL because I don't
think the NFL can near nearly touches me
excitement. Although having said that,
how great is it that it's fucking football season and this is what always
happened. Football season goes by like the summer, you know what I mean?
Like every year in the summer, I'm okay, it's May, we're going into May.
I'm really gonna pay attention and try to enjoy and remember like, hey,
it's this summer. We're in the summer. Let's fucking enjoy this shit.
I still feel that way.
Even though I live out in la where it's summer all the fucking time, right? Um,
and every, every fucking year, all of a sudden it's just like September, right?
And football seasons to same thing. You're like, oh my God,
fucking football season. It's fucking great. Then all of a sudden it's like,
it's the playoffs and you're so focused on the playoffs. Playoffs.
Then all of a sudden, like
it's that week between the championship game in the Super Bowl and you're like,
what the fuck happened?
You so busy putting money on the games and betting on the fucking games.
You don't realize, not only is there only one, two teams left,
there's only one game left and then then we're fucked.
Then we'll fuck. And then the panic starts to set and then you think,
well at least I got march madness, right?
At least they got march madness. And then I got the,
the hockey in the basketball playoffs and then there's just the, it's just,
you know what it really is. It's just July.
It's set one panic of July and into August.
The dog days of baseball
that you have to fucking deal with. That's how I ended up getting into fucking,
I think Formula One and all that shit just to cover that.
Then I totally got into it. I don't know.
I feel like I've been talking in circles for like fucking 25 minutes.
What is this? How many, how many awful minutes this has spent.
26 see that comedian long enough. You can, you can,
you could sense time.
I had this feeling that I'd been bombing for 26 fucking minutes.
So a congratulations to everybody's team who won this week,
including the chief's, not a cunt and a everybody last day. It's only funeral.
It's just one week fucking relax. Um,
25 days and no booze. 25 days to know the boobs.
I'll tell you how well I'm doing with no boots. When I went out,
I went through the duty free and I saw that
Macallan McCallum rare cask black, which I'd never heard of. And I am like,
I am fucking buying that
when I get back,
when I come back off the plane and when I got off the plane I, you know,
I think I flew delta out in United on the way back so it wasn't there but I was
going to buy it. You know, I'm sitting there talking to myself like, am I done?
Like I was actually thinking on the plane today,
like I might be done for good.
And then I came home and I ordered these whiskey glasses and I'm like,
well that's not a good sign.
Like if you just say I'm done with heroin and then you go to Amazon or you go to
like syringe.net, you know, and you just order a bunch of fucking
drug paraphernalia, I guess as long as you don't buy the drugs. Right. Hey,
I just gave officer I, I collect crack pipes. Okay, can I have,
can I have my license back please?
You're not going to find any residue in there.
Um, so anyway, I was actually thinking on the plane, I'm like, am I like,
what if I just next year I turned 50, right?
And I'm just done with the booze and then I just become like this yoga Palati
guy. I just go stink. Right? Gordon Sumner,
I become that fucking guy. You know,
I look good for my age. If I actually fucking did that through my fifties,
I would look fucking unbelievable.
It's 64 60 year old, you know? And you figured by then,
you know how good tanning beds are going to be,
how good the hair plugs are going to be, you know?
And I bet I'll be microchip by then,
which I can also have like the added Viagara uh,
option to it. You know what I mean?
I think I can stay in the game for another 10 years after that. I don't know.
What do you guys think? Have you guys thought about the future?
You that microchipped you full head of hair and abs?
Um, all right, let me read some advertising. Yeah. Oh,
speaking of fantasy football,
you know is the best thing about fantasy football.
Rather than sitting around fucking giving a hand job to your divorce buddy in
your own fucking living room during your stupid draft.
Why don't you go to draft kings and try to make some money cause you can least
afford some lotion a week.
One is in the books but it's not too late to get closer to the game you love
with draft kings one week fantasy football because of this site right there,
draft kings this Sunday draft kings is hosting a
$100,000 pick them contest that is totally free to enter.
Pick them is the newest way to play one week.
Fantasy drafting your team is faster than ever.
Draft Kings has organized players into eight tiers.
All you have to do is select one player from each tier three.
This is like doing an 18 t's. Now if you pick it perfectly,
you're telling me you want $1 billion. That's what they were saying.
Choose between public contests with big cash prizes or private contents where
you can compete against the group of know draft chains.
Also has a beginner in casual contest where you'll play against people of
similar skill level. Everybody wants to go home with a ribbon.
The best part is you get draft.
You get to draft a new team each week without any commitment, bitch, it's over.
So get to draft kings.com now and use Promo Code Berta.
Play in draft king draft kings free contest with the a hundred thousand dollars
in total prizes this Sunday.
Use My Promo Code burpee you are to play for free this Sunday. That's Promo Code
burr@draftkings.com eligibility restrictions apply.
Seep draft draftkings.com for details.
People try to have fun with that. Okay?
Don't fucking put your whole mortgage on it. All right. Okay,
here we go. Where am I going? Where am I going? Frame bridge everybody. Uh,
Jesus' frame bridge. You know what's frame bridges?
Will Jesus Christ is easiest way to custom frame your favorite art and photos
without ever leaving your house you fat.
Fuck with their simple online ordering project process.
You can order a fully custom customized piece in minutes.
Here's how it works. Yet you can fully customize your Dick Pics.
Somebody should do one. You know, we go to school pictures, whether it's you,
whether it's it's the double shot where it's you looking straight ahead and then
you looking up in the air. You've got to do a Dick kick version of that. Um,
here's how it works.
Go to Frame bridge.com upload your photos from your computer or directly from
your Instagram feed ladies.
Or if you have a physical item,
they'll provide secure prepaid packaging so you can mail it in for free.
Preview your photos online in any frame style.
Choose your favorite or get a free help from their talented designers,
the expert team at frame bridge. We'll customer,
we'll custom frame your item in days,
not weeks or months and deliver your finished piece directly to your door.
Ready to hang the best part instead of hundreds, you'd pay at a framing store.
Their prices start at just $39 all shipping is free.
Plus my listeners will get 15% off their first order@framebridge.com and they
use my code bar frame, which even offers a happiness guaranteed.
Are you happy if and for any reason you aren't 100% satisfied with your order,
they'll make it right. Give your personal experience using frame bridge.com oh,
I'll give it to you. Um, I've never used it.
I keep saying I'm going to use it. I keep taking pictures,
uploading them to my computers and then sticking them on the hard drives and end
up in the back of my closet.
And then I sit there and wonder what the fuck happened to them.
And I wished that I, I got some of them framed. So frame bridge, you like the,
you're the website that got away. You know that chick I should've said hello to,
you know, taken in at Bat. Um, the site is easy.
The site, the ease of order and have shut up man. Okay,
get ready to get started today. Framing your photos or art,
go to frame bridge.com and use the promo code bar.
You'll save an additional 15% off your first order. Just go to frame,
bridge.com Promo Code Burrow, framings.com Promo Code. All right,
last lastly, but not leastly. Oh Jesus Christ. Would you look who's back?
Would you look? Who's back? Ladies and gentlemen, stamps.com the original.
I think these are the first people ever advertised on my podcast.
Stamps saved you time and money,
which you can use to create cause if he didn't use a stamp,
you'd have to get in your current fucking deliver it yourself.
Right stamps save you time and money, which you can use to grow your business.
I can mail any letter,
any package using just my computer and Perretta and the fucking mailman comes
and picks it up. Avoid the hassle,
man of going to the post office and mail everything from postcards to envelopes
to packages, domestic or international. No drugs.
Create your stamps account in minutes online with no equipment to lease and no
longterm commitments. Click print mail and you're done. Unlike the post office,
stamps.com never closes.
Print postage for letters of packages at your own convenience.
24 seven buy and print official US postage for any letter, any package,
any class of mail using your own computer and printer stamps.com makes it easy.
They'll send you a digital scale. It automatically calculates the exact postage.
stamps.com will even help you decide the best class that mail based on your
needs.
No need to lease an expensive postage meter for the last fucking time.
I use stamps.com anytime I send out my posters.
Anytime I sell posters at the end of the show,
I'm a moron if I can figure it out. So can you,
and right now like this very many,
you too can enjoy the stamps.com service with a special offer that includes a
four week trial plus postage and a digital scale without longterm commitments.
Go to stamps.com click on the microphone at the top,
the home page and type of bird stamped.com a bar,
stamps.com never go to the post office again.
All righty there. That is done. That is done.
So I'm actually toying with that idea.
You know, no booze done,
done. I don't know if I can, I don't know.
I understand why alcoholics like they take it one day at a time cause she cause
just sitting there like I'm never going to do this. Not just today.
I'm just not going to do it today. Just not going to do it today.
You know, sometimes you got to do it though, right?
You know
your wife's talking to you and you're sitting there looking at her smiling and
nod.
She's thinking, Oh I love when he looks at me that way
he still
loves me. I can see it in his eye.
And you're actually thinking about that bottle of booze that you bought.
How are you going to go out in the garage? Like a fucking degenerate
sit some dirty chair. You don't give a shit, right?
Pour that glass. You set the bottle down, it touches the floor.
You hear it echoing in your garage. You know that garage that's yours, right?
That garage that you made the decision, you weren't going to be like these.
Most of these guys who let their wives not only take over the house but also the
garage, right? And they just fill it up with all this shit.
You can't even get the fucking car in their at garage is yours.
You put up the Dartboard,
you get the kegerator that sticks you little fucking tree for it, you know,
I mean, who was kicking talk. You're a guy yet you're still a child.
Just cause you can grow a beer doesn't mean you're mature. All right.
Would you look at all these stars doing these fucking commercials? Now?
Jesus fucking Christ. Can you leave something on the bone for the struggle?
Glenn actor,
can't you just do a fucking ad over in Guam like you used to?
Um, anyways,
well, well we'll dre waver.
I want to Redo my fucking garage again. Okay.
I gotta I gotta add something else in there. I got to add a fucking, you know,
now that I never have my truck in there, you know, I put it in storage,
so I kind of flip flop and everything like that with the new car and then the
old car. I haven't driven my truck in like two weeks, man. I miss it. Uh,
I gotta do that Sunday. I gotta have the garage with the fucking room above it.
You just have to have it at. That's what it is, you know?
And then once you do,
you have a fucking prenuptial agreement that if we get divorced,
I get the garage and the room above it and you cannot fucking evict me.
That will be mine and you will get the fucking house.
But you know something fucking,
they'll just be people. I just don't feel safe with him being out there,
cry their way into getting that to, you know,
I swear to God, um, I wonder if anybody,
like when a hurricanes come in and if they were in an unhappy marriage,
like what's going through their mind? You just sit in there with your wife,
you know, she doesn't know that you bought a boat.
You're tied to the back of the house, a little fucking row boat. You know,
she can't see it. You convince her to try it. Right.
Ride out the storm with a little water comes in you like see ya later. Oh,
Jesus, Bill.
Um, all right, let's get to the fucking questions this week. I apologize.
What do I, you know, and I don't apologize.
I don't apologize for fucking making up shit.
I'm making up Shit, man. What the fuck you want from me? All right, boo
lineups. Booz lineups that I talk about.
Everything I wanted to talk about first before I get into this shit.
Let's see here. Steven Adler, Ronnie James, Alabama verse Fresno State,
Mississippi Horseshoe ironing
board. Oh yeah. When I was waiting for the fucking car to come around,
I was standing out in front of the hotel going,
I'm never coming to this fucking state again. I was so fucking,
everything was going so god damn slow. But you know,
once I got over my five second temper Tantrum,
I realized that I actually had a great time there.
So I'm going to come back next time I'm coming back.
It's either when Ole Miss Mississippi state has a game.
I'm going to a fucking game that unhelped the plane out, Bam.
Or some shit like that. Um, Joe finds a Russian, I talked about that. No boots.
25 days.
Oh Billy fucking red velvet cakes was going to take a month off.
Now all of a sudden he thinks he's the next, he's the second commonest stink,
you know, staying held onto the hair.
He was losing the roof and then all of a sudden he started doing yoga.
He started standing on his fucking head and all that blood went to the top of
his head, started feeding the roots. And that's what happened.
Maybe mine will come back.
Fantasy football has taken over trading cards and all that shit.
I talked about that. Well, I guess it's time to get on the fucking with the, uh,
the Booz lineups here. All right. It's guys Booz lineup. Hey, Billy Balah chops.
Uh, I'm a listener from a listener from the UK. I,
uh, by the way, it's 16 to three. Well, you guys already know this shit.
Dallas plains, some good defense. I'm a listener from the UK.
I managed to get to your show in Manchester and it was brilliant. Ah, thank you.
I was nervous about that show. You know,
all I knew was this fucking soccer hoodlums from the 80s. You know,
the fucking neo Nazis falling around man United. That's all I knew.
I read among the thugs and to me that was Manchester. Um,
he said I wanted to send you my team of drinks, but I don't watch baseball. Oh,
you're batting lineup. Okay. I tried when I was in New York to watch baseball,
but I found it boring. Same with football. Fucking boring a,
he means soccer here I guess. Cause he says la watched for that,
for the World Cup. I mainly watch rugby league.
You watch that seven nation league where if you come in last,
you get the wooden spoon. Um, NFL for the Seahawks cricket.
And I'm a big fan of F1. Dude, if you can sit through fucking cricket,
you can get through a baseball game. I mean,
that's the same thing except cricket last for fucking five days. Um,
I decided to send you my list of drinks as the Formula One teams.
I don't really drink that many neat spirits or whiskey,
so I included everything else I drink when I want to get pissed. All right.
Leading off, he's gotten,
Mercedes is Mercedes-Benz team for those of you don't want you F1 they're like
the fucking cream of the crop. Uh,
we really should have batting cleanup,
but I get this, you're gonna do this more like,
you know how they ranked football teams the best to the worst. All right. Uh,
IPA beers. Yeah, I'm one of those guys,
but I know piss people off talking about it. My pole position,
drink quite happy to drink these beers all night. Drink iph all night.
Jesus Christ. It's like drinking a Thanksgiving dinner. Each pint is so fucking,
I fucking hate. I, there's so fucking I, you know,
every once in a while if I just want to have one beer,
but I know I'm going to drink 30, I'll have an IPA.
Cause by the time I'm done with it, I'm just like, Jesus Christ had enough,
enough with the fucking hops. Good Lord.
It's like overactive. Quit bugging your eyes out of your fucking head. I get it.
Beer supposed to have hops. Well,
as long as you don't drink any of those stupid beers that have those,
those aggressive for no reason. Names, you know,
angry fuck face kick your mother and the current beer, whatever they, lamps,
Ale, angry Ale. All right.
His second better would be the Ferrari team, Jack Daniels Black Label,
old number seven, whatever you want to call it.
A been around for these all these years and it's,
and it is as popular as it's always been. Usually drink it with a coke.
Rarely neat. Oh Jesus. This guy's not even in AAA here.
Batting third red bull mount gate with Mount Gay Eclipse Rum.
All right. If you're in your twenties I forgive you for this lineup.
I've been drinking it with ginger beer since these guys were Jaguar or the red
ball of side, the red bull team. I'm a fucking idiot. Some sorry.
I thought you drinking red bulls in mount gay eclipse rum. I was like,
what in the fuck. Oh, I'm sorry. I apologize. All right. For Cindy,
a team is, is a brown of vodcast. Never heard of that.
Usually with apple juice. Don't get me,
I'll see you drink like a woman you see with apple juice and a little umbrella
in there and I thought it's been around a couple of times and I looked fatness.
I'm new to good vodka like a few Brits.
I was drinking a paint stripper. VOD Paint,
striper vodka and red bull from 17. Um, all right.
The Williams Stella are toys logger. Okay.
William's team is to stellar our toast. I don't know how to say half the shit.
The old dependable, I never heard of it, but doesn't win many races anymore.
Still nothing beats turning up at a mate's house with the crate of Stella for a
day of drinking. Toro Rosso team would be sailor Jerry rum.
This guy's a rum drinker.
When I started drinking rum and move to the red bull team not long after.
All right, Molly, she didn't mix that with anything. The Haas,
the American Formula One. Jack Daniel's single barrel one for the Americans.
There you go. The only whiskey I really drink. Neat. Good man.
There's hope for you. Renaud [inaudible] team a bitter, uh,
the classic British British drink, which has not served warm.
It's served at cellular seller temperature. I don't even know what bitter is.
McLaren Yeager Meister, not as good as it used to be,
but I have some great nights drinking this stuff.
How the fuck anybody drinks more than one of those as beyond me. Uh,
the soccer team, I don't know who that is. Bringing up the rear. It's cider.
Not even close to a goto drink, but I'm glad it's there. I fucking hate cider.
I love the podcast is for family and all the specials. Come back to the UK soon.
Thanks. And Go fuck yourself. I'll definitely be back there.
Thank you for your Booz lineup. Um,
there was actually a couple interesting things in there.
Yeah,
that's a brow vodka. I never heard of that. But you know,
I'm going to do yoga and pilates for the rest of my life.
I'm going to age like sting. Granted he started doing that Shit in his thirties.
Alright, number two. All right. Uh, um,
okay.
Question number two or whatever the fuck I'm doing this week.
A Ron stone ball bag.
Billy loved the podcast and love when you rip into the more on simply for being
more on this, keep it up. That's why I trash myself so much.
I wanted to throw down a Booz lineup, but for hockey. All right, here we go.
We're going for more booze line and I feel like this is getting old people.
I'm going to read this last one that's going to be it for the booze lineups and
every once in a while we'll do it. Uh, we need some more overrated, underrated,
uh, center. The Cindy Krabi position.
Miller genuine draft. I hate that beer. God bless you. Somebody's got a drink.
It, you pay a little too much for anybody's,
your franchise players so you have no choice.
Left wing is Weiser's black label,
smooth dangles and sets everyone else up.
Right wing is Santiago 16 year Cuban run rum.
Foreign player.
Other teams are afraid to sign that plays his ass off every night,
but take some stupid penalties. Demon number one, Jack Daniels, safe, gritty,
defensive minded and d and You didn't break the cap. Hit Forum d man,
two cores light never misses a game. Jumps up in the zone,
but on the wrong end of the odd man rush is too often goalie.
His crown royal hometown boy that gives you 65 starts as season and always gives
you a chance. Partner would love that lineup.
I don't know about Miller genuine draft,
but he'd love that you've finished with crown royal. Uh,
thanks and go fuck yourself. All right.
Okay,
now we're on, now we're onto some fucking questions here. Uh,
all right, the fucker. We, uh, Bill.
What is this? This is more fucking football. I can't do this. This is,
there's too many Booz lists here. What's this going to get?
Boring because it requires me to really read out loud, which I'm not good at.
All right. Fingerprinting students.
Okay.
What in the fuck is happening to this world? Hey Billy Bo.
Baggins I'll try to keep this short.
I just started college and in the dining halls,
they now only use fingerprint scanners to let you in.
Cooking is not allowed in the dorms. So if you want to eat,
you have to give them your fingerprints. I'm not one of those.
I got shipped slash free tee shirt people. But what else can I do?
Your thoughts would be appreciated. Thanks. And Go fuck yourself. Well,
millennials, I think it's time. You guys fucking rebel.
You got to rebel against something here.
I'll go to subway.
Why do they need your fucking fingerprints and what are they going to do with
them? Even if they're not going to do anything with them,
they're going to hack into the your system.
Somebody's going to hack into the system that's so fucking nuts.
That is legit. I honestly have to look up like how, how are,
how do people justify taking your fucking fingerprints to give you a fucking
slice of pizza?
How do colleges justify taking students fingerprints?
I love how the mainstream fucking pussy ass fucking corporate media never talks
about this shit. They just sell people out.
They're just such follies fucking idiots screaming about Trump and Hillary and
this is what they're doing to citizens of this fucking country.
It's fucking unbelievable.
Can I refuse to have my child fingerprinted at school?
Background of fingerprinting. I got, ah, Jesus. I almost lied to you guys.
I got to read up on this like I'm actually gonna do this.
Should schools fingerprint your kids?
Isn't that a big, what is this for? Let me guess. It's for our own protection.
All they do is make gift bags for people that know how to go on the Internet and
steal shit. Here it is.
Here's the fucking social security number with the fingerprints,
the home address, all the relatives. All in a nice, neat, nice,
neat little fucking bag.
Yeah.
I can't fucking believe that this, these fucking jerk offs,
these fucking jerk offs. Anybody Watches Fox and CNN as a fucking jerk off.
When was the last time they held the feet of of the the fucking constantly doing
all of this shit at the end of the fire. When the fuck are they ever done that?
Yeah.
Have they ever really gone off the pharmaceutical companies for starting a
heroin epidemic?
Had they ever really gone after Monsanto for fucking with the food supply?
Have they ever really gone after bankers for what the fuck they were allowed to
get away with 10 fucking years ago? Jesus fucking Christ.
You do one off colored fucking joke.
They cover that more than these fucking insurance companies are probably gonna
fuck everybody over. Ah, now I'm upset.
Okay.
You know what I would do, sir?
I would fucking somehow go out of my own pocket and I would fucking eat down the
street for fucking cheap the best I could.
That's why you can still bring snacks. You can't cook.
You could still have a fridge, right? I need a bowl of fucking cereal.
I would eat a fucking bowl of cereal three days a week,
three times a fucking day before I'd get those fucking cons.
You goddamn fingerprints. First of all, you,
all you're going to do is come out of college.
You're going to be all these student loans and what sort of job as even to be
there. You've got to give me a fingerprints to fuck these people. Fuck up.
Yeah.
You know, I dunno. You're not even allowed to fucking protest anymore.
You'd have to go to a certain section.
You'd have to get a fucking permit to protest.
Do I guaran fucking tee you?
I guarantee you the reason why they're taking your fingerprints is an added
revenue stream and they're going to, you know, they're,
they're going to fucking sell them to somebody else.
All of those fucking people that take your fucking information.
How are we getting weed seed safe? It's secure. It isn't safe and secure.
What they've done now is they've made it a lot easier for these people that go
in and steal shit rather than having to having to break into you personally.
They just break into a company and they get like a flu or whatever,
a couple thousand people a whack.
And then what kills me is after these cons, take your information,
their system gets hacked into and you can, you sue them
for putting your shit up there. It's fucking unreal.
Anyways, I just recently had, you know,
a TV network that I worked for sent me a fucking letter.
She go in there and go read it and say, uh, you know,
unfortunately someone broke into our system and um, the,
a lot of personal information was, might've been exposed.
So all they're required to do after, it's like,
why did you keep all that information?
We need to go back to paper and file cabinets. People, I'm telling you,
make these fucking pieces of shit. Look,
cat burglar outfits have the flashlight in their mouth is they tried to pick the
lock to go in. I'm sorry. I really just lost my shit there,
but I feel like my,
I know even though I didn't have all the information I needed to,
to make a logical argument, I, I feel like I am right.
I'm sniffing around something there. All right. Alcoholics anonymous.
Hey Bill. I was in AA for roughly two years. If you thinking about attending,
I would suggest you visit a library and get the AA big book.
Sometimes they have a copy available. I would read it. Okay.
Now you just asked me to do two things that are really difficult for me. One,
going to a library and to finding a book and then three,
actually three reading it. Um, what else you want me to do? Dunk a basketball.
You're really getting outside the realm of what I do here. Uh,
then I would also read the orange papers and online website,
which attempts to debunk the AAA philosophy,
attend a few meetings and get a feel for it. But honestly,
I don't think you're an alcoholic from listening to your podcast.
I just think you're a piss head a. You can put a cork in the bottle.
I hear you sometimes beating yourself up when you've had three large pours. Oh,
Jesus. Relaxed. That's not alcoholism. I love this guy.
Sure. You're probably not a drinker,
but it's all on a spectrum and you seem to be doing fine when you start
drinking, cleaning gel mixed with fruit juice because it has alcohol in it.
Then we can talk. I've heard it all in AA and,
and you don't qualify for the club in my humble opinion. Take it easy.
You're bald. Fuck. All right. Well thank you for the kind words sir. Um,
no, but it's also, it's not good for you.
I can tell you it's not to the level that I was drinking was not good for you.
Um, but I, and I also don't think AA is bad. If it works for you,
then I think it's good. If it doesn't work for you,
I don't think you then have to go out and debunk it.
What kind of a cut does that like alcohol and non alcoholic anonymous has helped
so many fucking people. Let me look at the orange papers.
The fuck's the asshole who just say everybody just always has to rain on
somebody's parade. Orange papers here.
I just realized somebody might be fucking riding out this hurricane down in
Florida listening to this podcast. If you still have power,
if you get a generator and I just said rain. Rain on your fucking parade.
Sorry. Um, what are the orange papers? Orange papers.
I spelled orange wrong. I put two ends in there.
I don't know why I said O r n a n g orange papers. AA.
Here we go.
Orange papers recovering from recovery anti a sites such as orange papers.
All right,
now this is just going to be another website that just hijacked the whole
fucking thing so I can't get to it. Where are the original orange papers?
Original. Original, please, please. Can I get the original?
I can't find it.
I cannot fucking find it. What the fuck? Come on man. All right.
I just clicked on this page and I see a pig picture of a monkey leaving.
AA staying sober. All right. Here we go.
For some of the suffering alcoholic in those unhappy in AA.
Okay.
All right. Let's see what they bitch about here.
For the suffering alcoholic and those unhappy in AA,
alcoholics anonymous has over 2 million participants globally. That's it.
It is a friendly and welcoming organization with many caring, helpful members.
AA offers companionship, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
If you think you have a drinking problem and haven't tried AA,
stop reading this essay and go to a meeting. However,
growing number of options is solely because I didn't want to fucking read all of
this shit. All right. I'll take your word for it evidently.
Okay.
Look at Eli stepping up in the pocket.
What's the score? Yeah.
Okay.
16 to three, seven minutes to go. Did he just throw a pick?
Who knows? All right.
Wife working out with Ex. Oh, Jesus. Fucking Christ.
If I saw that at the beginning of a fucking porno, I'd be like, oh my God,
can we come up with a fucking less cliched scenario?
Okay.
Um, okay. Hey, the ability read sack, love your podcast. Love F is for family.
Can't wait for season three. I wanted your advice on something.
Here's the story.
I got married about a year ago and me and my lovely wife moved to La right after
the wedding because she had a great job opportunity.
She had lived in La a few years ago prior to meeting me and when she was living
here, she had a fling with some douche chief private fitness trainer.
Both of them viewed marriage as a stupid concept and they made a pact that when
they'll get married, other people they'd meet up and fuck,
I don't believe a fucking word of this.
I don't believe a fucking word of this. This is too stupid.
They made it back.
When when they'll get married to other people,
they'd meet up and fuck.
I mean that definitely sounds like an la conversation in a gym.
I'll continue reading. Uh,
so as soon as she changed her relationship status status to married on Facebook,
that guy sent her a bunch of messages which were sexual and pretty much offend.
Oh, offered to take her up on the agreement and fuck.
She didn't respond, but she did tell me about it,
but I didn't lose my shit in remain calm in the last few weeks.
She told me she's looking for a way to get in shape and she said that the do.
She had offered her private workout sessions in exchange for help in his
business. She's an accountant.
She said that because private workout sessions are expensive and he's very good
at what he does. This is a great opportunity that would save us some money.
She said she made it clear to him that she's happily married and nothing is
going to happen and he understood completely.
She asked me if it bothers me and I not wanting to look like the insecure,
jealous type, all my God, you fucking dude.
I'm telling you these fucking women are in guys heads.
All of this bullshit that you've seen on fucking TV,
all of these fucking women fucking playing the victim all the time.
All of this fucking coverage of just what guys do to women has now every fucking
guy has his balls in his fucking back pocket.
And it's just like, well,
I don't want to be the guy that fucking makes you uncomfortable. Okay.
What would she fucking tolerate this from you?
You don't want to look into, that's not being in secure, sir.
That's common fucking sense. So he said,
honestly, honey,
I trust you. I want what's best for you.
And tried actually to do that. Okay.
My question is, do you think she's trustworthy? Possible, but that guy isn't.
Hmm.
And that guy's just drawn her in because he wants to fuck her.
Okay.
Um, she does have a history of cheating on her exes,
but so do I. We both been happily married in our sex life is great,
but still the doubt and insecurity about that issue. This issue exists.
Love to hear your take on this. Can't wait for the new hour's special. Thanks.
And Go fuck yourself, buddy, buddy. Yet no, no,
no fucking way. No fucking way. Work some extra hours.
You know,
I would actually be willing to believe that she's going over there thinking
she's not going to do anything, but that guy's going to seducer.
That's what's going to happen. They already banged. They're already, you know,
physically like, you know,
yeah.
You know, the boundaries are not going to be there.
And I'm telling you that that's not a good situation and you're not in,
you're not in secure it all,
you know.
And so what if you are, that's a legitimate,
that's a legitimate feeling, that full fucking thing.
Let's do stupid fucking tee shirts. I saw this,
there's some woman was wearing this fucking tee shirt.
I told you what that one is back in the summertime.
It said something like [inaudible]
a real man is excited by a strong woman. A boy is like whatever,
intimidated or something like that. So there's some musical, oh, I want to be,
I want to be considered a strong man. I want a cookie.
I was reading that rolling stone where they had the, the,
the actress that was playing, uh, played wonder woman.
And I was all excited to read the article. And the first quote that they had,
the, they said, are you a feminist? She goes, yes, I'm a feminist.
Everyone should be a feminist because if you're not a feminist,
then you're a sexist. Right.
Okay.
And I like bursting out laughing thinking like, well,
it all depends on what your definition is.
Yeah,
yeah. That's what's funny about these Hollywood people out here. I swear to God,
they sound just like the Fox News, right? People did the exact, that you know,
old Zara is zero tolerance. You think the way I go. If you do not,
then you are this. Um,
like there's no clear cut definition of feminism any more than there is of like
what makes like, you know,
that's real rock music and then somebody's always like Dutch, not rock dishes,
Rock Dad's bullshit. It's the same thing with like family.
Like everyone was a feminist the way my wife is, which, you know,
in all fairness, this actress that played one woman could be,
I don't fucking know. But just to say like that, it's just such a, I mean,
granted, it's a fucking interview.
They're trying get people fucking worked up to read the fucking thing.
Maybe it was taken out of context. Maybe she said other shit,
but just the way that's presented, you know,
rolling stone is just fucking insufferable though.
It's just fucking insufferable.
The way they handled Obama with like kid gloves and if you're a fucking
Republican, they stick your head in the fire.
Now I'm not saying they shouldn't stick these Republicans head in the fire.
I mean they're the fucking, you know, the, the,
they bought and paid for it that level. Right. Am I nuts?
And I also thought by Obama was too,
judging by the $69 million worth of tour dates he has coming up,
giving speeches to all these fucking rich people.
Guy Just bought a $10 million fucking house. It's fucking unreal.
And they don't say shit. All they do is show him playing,
highlight and fucking go and kayaking and parasailing. Like, isn't it
cool? I carefully don't call. He is.
Um,
anyways, by the way, rolling stone. Is Trump the worst president ever?
I haven't noticed. He, it's not like you haven't fucking written it.
It's just like, I don't even read the fucking article.
It's like I understood your point of view. The first 90 articles,
there's so much other shit you could be writing about. You know what I mean?
Okay,
good fucking Lord. Like my,
why can't you make fun of like extreme liberals every once in a while?
Throw me a fucking curve ball, something. Ah, Jesus Christ.
I'd fucking need to go buy some fucking tampons here. I'm sorry.
You know what it, when it happened,
you know what the funny stopped was the fingerprint of these fucking poor kids,
these four kids are going to college, they're getting it all in fucking debt.
Alright.
And these colleges are acting like they've adapted to how quickly the real world
is changing. And I don't think they are.
And that's why these kids are coming out.
It's like they're coming out with degrees in like fucking,
I don't know what the fucking, uh, churning butter essentially,
and then they can't find a fucking job. You know?
I don't know.
I remember like always reading up about all these fucking amazing musicians.
They would go to Berkeley and they would, they would never come.
Like the guys that went out and seen the guys that went out and did shit,
they never finished. Like they will like this, this whole be in here.
I got what I needed. Now I got to get the fuck Outta here. And um,
I'm not saying drop out of college,
but I really feel like a [inaudible] if that voice is screaming in your head and
you, you fucking have some good ideas. Why take on the last year a debt,
the last, you know why? Because your parents want you to,
um,
I dunno what, because Bill Gates dropped out a few drop out. I'm just saying,
you know what the fuck I ended up doing.
I didn't need to go to college at all this fucking village student loan,
all that debt.
And I left and I immediately went down to a comedy club and started doing shit
jokes.
Okay.
Um, anyways,
we got to end on something positive here. Uh, please go to that Steve.
And I'll add the Ronnie James thing. Uh,
I'm going to post that the bowl for Ronnie. Ronnie James,
what a fucking voice and what a great guy too, man. I never met the guy,
but like Paul, his interviews, he could have been more down to Earth a,
once again, it's gonna be at pins, P I n z bowling center, one, two, six,
five five Ventura Boulevard A. It's gonna be a bunch of rock stars.
They're a bunch of comedians. All bowling raising money for, uh,
I don't even know what the, what is the cause here? Vinyl.
Ronnie died of cancer. So imagine it's that, right? Oh, Ronnie,
Ronnie James Dio. Stand up and shout a cancer. Fun.
There you go. Stand up and shout right. Um,
so there's something positive for you and I believe it's October 6th. All right.
I will be tweeting that out and I am trying to get back onto Instagram.
I haven't posted on Instagram and forever.
I think I have to create an entirely new account because I keep saying I forgot
my password. Please email it to me.
And they haven't been able or I haven't been able,
I can't find the fucking thing. I'm so that's it.
That's the podcast for this week. Congratulations to everybody. One week, one,
congratulations to all football fans. That is football season.
Um, my favorite fucking thing happened this weekend, by the way,
when I was in the Alabama theater,
there was this fucking guy in the front row and he had his middle aged too.
We had his cell phone on, it's a middle aged guy and I'm like, dude,
he you the show you recording the show. And he kind of was like, no. He goes,
he goes,
I'm looking at the scores because it was Saturday night and he wanted to see how
the other SCC teams were doing. And I go, well, what's what,
what are you watching? He was watching the Georgia game. I go with your Alabama.
The fuck do you give a shit about Georgia four? He goes there in the SCC. I go,
they're not gonna Catch Ya. They got that decent quarterback though.
I don't know. Then the crowd kind of dies down and this guy in the back goes,
he says to the guy with the phone, he just goes, excuse me sir, sir? He goes, a,
what'd he say? Oh fuck. I'm going to put you the joke. Auburn,
Clemson, whoever the fuck Auburn was playing, it was like,
I wasn't even there anymore. He just asked for a score.
Okay.
Oh God. What a fucking great setup.
It would have been such a killer story if I could have fucking remembered
Auburn score. What do we got here? That's right.
They played Clemson. Yeah. He goes, excuse me sir. Auburn. Clemson.
That's all he had to say.
The guy sits right on his phone looking to give him the fucking score. Um,
I dunno. It's a great fucking place. Don't sleep on the south. Alright.
If you really think about it, you're states just as racist. Okay. That's it.
Go fuck yourselves. Um, I don't know what else to tell Ya.
Check in on you on Thursday. I hope. Um, you know,
my hope is a little damage in Florida as humanly possible and that's all you can
fucking hope for. And um, you know,
while you guys make fun of people driving electric cars, I don't know.
Now you know what the fuck I drive gas combustion cars.
So I'm not fucking looking down on you, but you know,
I don't know what the battery does in the end.
When you drive the Tesla into the fucking ocean, can you recycle the battery?
I have no idea.
But I'll tell you what that guys doing over there at that Tesla company.
I like it. I like it. I just wished the car could look a little more meaner.
It looks great from the back. Looks great from the side. The front.
I don't know what it is.
Okay.
Just can't quite get into it. But uh, I know it's a fucking amazing car,
but then they SUV is fucking cool, Huh?
The Lamborghini doors opening up a plus.
It's also a great way to win the war in the Middle East, you know?
Yeah.
Drive an electric car. You ride a bicycle,
anything you do to use less fucking fossil fuels,
fucks those people over over there and they don't have money to funnel through
the moss to give to the terrorist. And there you go. And all of a sudden, oh,
Jimmy, crack corns out of fireworks, right? Oh,
I just saw the Middle East or problem or the Middle East problem.
Not Middle Eastern. I don't have problems with Middle Eastern people
and this is why I don't hold off this. All right. Go fuck yourselves people.
I'll talk to you on Thursday.